Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
Oh my God we have to break this poster and
this title down, so there are a couple really
big things long time Star Wars fans will immediately
notice some of the visual similarities in
this poster to a previous poster from another
Star Wars film I've got a really funny clip
of Mark Hamill talking about his original
idea for episode 7 and then we gotta talk
about when the gonna drop the first teaser
there is a new round of the Star Wars giveaway
for IMAX gift certificates.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a Star Wars related comment on this
video so this is very specific about what
this movie is going to focus on the poster
it itself.
It reminds you of return of the Jedi the title
that was actually what the teaser poster for
return of the Jedi look like.
And even revenge of the Jedi before they changed
the title to return of the Jedi Easter egg
and there is the lot of the tone of this red
text implies that is gonna be a little bit
darker than the first film is also going to
be a return of Luke Skywalker return of the
Jedi.
So the force awakens was all about the awakening
of raise character in the force in general
and a number of other characters.
So was like the force had been dormant for
a long time.
Although not in the truest sense of the word,
and it was coming back.
But now the last Jedi just makes you feel
like the whole movie is going to be about
Luke Skywalker because people wonder.
You know what does that title actually mean
the last Jedi who are they talking about it
is Jedi plural because now Rey is trained
to be a Jedi.
So the thing is is sometimes when you look
at the way they translate posters and titles
into other languages you can find out what
they intended based on male or female pronouns
so on the poster they released in Brazil it
actually read mail and singular, so that implies
that the title is supposed to be for Luke
not for Rey and it's not for both of them,
just because Rey is not a Jedi yet she just
met Luke Skywalker in an Empire strikes back
Luke Skywalker did the same thing were he's
like I'm a Jedi now, and every other force
users that he was in proximity to during that
movie like Yoda Obi-Wan Kenobi even Darth
Vader said that his training was not finished
all complete your training, we can rule the
galaxy together so Luke Skywalker's like all
yeah got some training.
I'm totally Jedi everyone just like nope not
even close to Rey is just beginning the path
to becoming a Jedi presumably shall get there
by the third movie in the way that Luke Skywalker
finally became a Jedi when he came to terms
with his father, and help save him.
So Luke Skywalker we gotta talk all about
Luke Skywalker, Mark Hamill has said all kinds
of funny stuff about getting ready for the
force awakens like he lost a ton of weight.
You got back into shape and did not know that
when he showed up on set, all they wanted him
to do was just turn around wearing these heavy
Jedi robes and pull the hood back. He said
he was a little upset.
He was excited to be back for Star Wars.
He was a little upset because, he's been prepared for
this big action set piece because he thought
that he was going to enter the movie when
Han Solo was killed.
His idea was that he would actually come see
his friend I it would be more meaningful my
problem with that death was I said why is
that you know what should happen.
There's no character the really besides chewy
that has a real deep connection to him.
So it's his is death doesn't have the resonance, that it would have if Leia witnessed it
or if Luke was rushing back to save him and was
just not, you know,  too late as I thought, when I
was reading that I said oh yeah she's trying
to contact me in the earlier films she could
do with ESP and I said, I know that I'm not
showing up to the end a batch I'll show up
like on coming back at the beginning of the
first one to the death Star.
I'll show up in the last nine minutes, but I'll
be just too late for to save Han, but all allowed
the new antagonists to succeed.
Believe me I did know was just to be a pivot
load good removal.
I mean I train twice a week for 50 weeks per
that I thought I'm going to do something great.
Well okay I do not only that but I be I lost
all this weight and then they put me in these
roads I said I don't is to be Jabba the Hutt
and it's always so funny listening to the
original cast sort of talk about what their
thoughts on the film are outside of the film
itself that you usually expect them to hype
it up, but they have their own ideas about
a two in the idea of the wasted Mark Hamill
bad ass re-that could happen in episode seven,
but that will definitely not happen in episode
aid because since Ryan Johnson's been shooting
it.
They've actually posted a couple behind-the-scenes
images they been so hard-core about security
it is ridiculous what Mark Hamill says that
security is like they were security robes
over their normal close, but they have released
a picture of Luke's clothing the staff here.
You just you don't see a lot of stuff out
here.
You just see a little bit about the way that
he's a live this whole time always been in
isolation.
So back to the title again the last Jedi Luke
Skywalker you have to imagine that he's the
last.
That was trained by traditional Jedi and now
that he's gone back like the whole big thing
about this new trilogy is in getting back
to what the original intent of the forces,
but the original interpretation.
It was perverted over time by both the Jedi
and other factions like the Sith, so you have
snow on one side you have Luke on the other,
but both are trying to take a different interpretation
of the force.
Then they were taught previously know there's
even less information about snow but I actually
think that that's a good thing we didn't really
learn about the Emperor until Empire strikes
back and then really didn't get to see him
that much until the final movie.
So I'm totally cool with that same paradigm.
But if you haven't been watching it Star Wars
rebels has been doing this really interesting
thing with the way it reinterprets the force,
they just did this big dark saber episode.
They actually brought Knights of the Old Republic
back into the Canon printer previously density
Old Republic Darth Revan all that stuff almost
made it into the Canon during the clone wars,
George Lucas pulled like a hard pass was like
nope put Darth Bain in Darth Revan's out.
So Knights of the Old Republic was not Canon
at all change this past weekend.
Another thing they did earlier this year with
the interpretation of the force was bring
back the Bendu George Lucas's original name
for the Jedi in the way the Bendu that he
practices the force a very different way.
There's the light side the Dark Side I'm the
one in the middle.
So don't if that's is outright that Luke is
turning into a gRey Jedi or anything like
that I think in searching for the ox to planet.
That's the name of the planet that he's on
in the original Jedi Temple, he just seeking
to find the truth of things that he felt was
lost over time.
So one of the most exciting things about this
one.
Obviously, the title says Jedi.
So is gonna be a shit load of Jedi stuff happening
at it but to also get a lot of new mythology
that will reinterpret and recontextualize
a lot of the old movies to they did that,
during Rogue one with the death Star weakness
where it's like does this in a really funny
story beat the dozen totally makes sense.
Why would the Empire build such a crappy design
will turns out it was on purpose.
So the gins father could aid the rebels and
they be able to destroy it.
So just think of the way they're treating
the force in these new movies is doing that
for the force in the previous movies to that's
why you don't hear about mid chlorine's or
anything like that Luke himself is going back
to rewrite a lot of that Canon and raise going
to learn it the right way, so should be a
very different kind of Jedi when she does
complete her training of the cool thing is
that on the other side of that so will Kylo
Ren it's implied that the same thing is happening
with smoke right now.
Now he doesn't have the information that Luke
has but presumably he has a lot of dark knowledge
that has nothing to do with the Sith because
they said that the Sith isn't really a thing
in the new trilogy now all religious orders
all over the galaxy haven't been wiped out
there's probably a couple people that still
believe in the Sith.
Somewhere out there is just that snow can
Kylo Ren are not part of the Sith.
The just the way they explain it going into
the force awakens so you guys can let me know
what you most excited about seeing the new
force abilities and the new force lore that
Luke Skywalker has learned about or about
the stuff that snow is teaching Kylo Ren because
most of the force powers that Kylo Ren displayed
in the first movie.
And even Daisy Ridley's character were rudimentary
you know Jedi mind trick things that you saw
in episode four pretty basic stuff.
Pretty basic lightsaber fight.
I'm not expecting to see any of that and whatever
the first teaser is, but a lot of the language
that they use implies some of the past that
they'll be taking.
So the first real trailer is probably not
going to drop to Star Wars celebration in
April, but because they release the title
the teaser poster for the force awakens right
before they release the first teaser.
They might also release a short teaser, really
soon now like not this month maybe next month.
Maybe in March.
So just be prepared for some actual Star Wars
episode eight footage to drop.
But what's going to happen is because now
it's time to start freaking out about Star
Wars episode eight be doing a lot more bonus
videos please leave all your request for what
you want those to be about in the comments
tomorrow onto another bonus video about new
Luke Skywalker powers the nature of the force
just talking about more Jedi specific stuff,
so that should post in the morning while you
guys wait for that to post you can click here
for my Dark Side Rey video and you can click
here for the greatest Darth Vader seen in
the history of cinema that you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight!